hey guys it's justine and look what we
have today we have the brand new mac
studio and the studio display i also
have my little shop back here so i'm
gonna go shopping we're gonna have the
new magic mouse the new magic trackpad
and the new magic keyboard with touch id
[Music]
oh
my
goodness here you are little friend such
an interesting little unboxing
experience check this out
[Music]
do you want to get a tick-tock of that
look at this wow okay so i actually
thought it was going to be heavier than
it is the ultra version of the mac
studio is actually two pounds heavier to
accommodate for different cooling
factors which is kind of interesting and
because i read that i actually thought
this was going to be heavier so all
things considered
it's not that heavy at all we also have
our charging cable which is a nice
braided black cable get some paperwork
here which i think that we have apple
stickers
oh
wow look at this
beautiful debuff
i just need a minute i just need a
minute oh it smells so good
this is great oh my god i can't wait to
plug it in we need a display well good
thing that we have one the new studio
display
this is so exciting and this is
something i think that people have been
waiting for a less expensive version of
the pro display xtr granted i think this
might be a little bit out of some
people's price ranges just if they want
a basic display when you're buying
something obviously from apple you're
not buying basic
[Music]
i know you guys watch my videos and you
see my excitement but
i'm so excited in case i didn't tell you
i
um it's upside down wait a minute
this is the bottom oh you know why
because you're supposed to lay it down
this is how you're supposed to open it
that makes so much more sense time to
take you out of your box
this is very similar to the m1 imac
boxes that they have you ow look at you
look at you it's crazy
this in comparison to the pro display
xcrs that thing is so thick so heavy
like this is such
a more manageable
weight and size looks like we've also
got some paperwork
oh no this is actually
a thunderbolt cable this is a prized
possession and it's the braided cable
this is so nice
what a treat apple sticker apple sticker
two apple stickers oh my gosh and a
bonus polishing cloth do you know how
hard these are to get all right let's
check out this display now so it looks
like back here we have a little surprise
it has like a little backpack this is
probably
our power adapter i'm gonna assume
oh look at that nicely wrapped up
it looks so good oh my goodness
oh another one are you ready for this
oh
this is the nano texture display as well
this looks so
good smells good as well this is awesome
do a little spin for us time to set them
up
[Music]
so here it is the brand new mac studio
and the studio display it's all set up
and i've been using it for the past
couple of days now the mac studio is
such an interesting little computer and
i don't want you guys to be fooled by
just looking at this small little tiny
box because what's inside of this thing
is actually really impressive it's so
impressive that i'm
i'm speechless and that's a lie because
i actually have so much to say that i
feel like i'm probably not gonna have
enough room on the cf express card to
say it all especially because we're
shooting in ak anyway let's start out
with what is m1 because i feel like a
lot of people who might be watching this
maybe for the first time have just heard
of the m1 processor and you might be a
little bit confused up until a few years
ago apple was using all intel processors
in all of their computers until they
surprised us with the announcement of
the m1 apple silicon chip and this is
something that they are now taking
in-house which is kind of incredible
because this is allowing apple to really
take full ability of their software and
hardware and making sure everything is
working seamless and why this is
important is apple now has the ability
to tailor their hardware and software
for the most compatibility so if they're
working on not only the processor that
they're putting inside of the hardware
that also allows them to fine-tune the
software to work with everything and
just really keep this apple ecosystem
going and so far i have been more than
impressed by the performance of the m1
chips in not only the 13-inch but the
macbook pro to the m1 imac and even the
m1 mac mini but now that kind of brings
us to where we are currently where we
have this little box right here that has
an m1 ultra chip now this is actually
two m1 max chips put together so this
was kind of a surprise in the latest
announcement because they were like oh
hey by the way there's something that we
didn't tell you about that last m1 chip
that we released we're adding one last
chip to the m1 family and it's gonna
blow your mind the m1 max oh yeah we can
actually put those both together so that
they can simultaneously act as one
there's actually two versions of the mac
studio the first one has the m1 max chip
and that's starting at 1999 with 10 core
cpu 24 core gpu which you can upgrade to
32 16 core neural engine 400 gigabytes a
second memory bandwidth and up to 64
gigs of ram and that brings us to the
device that i've been testing out with
the m1 ultra chip and this is starting
at 39.99 and with those two m1 max chips
connected together they're calling that
the ultra fusion architecture so this
has a 20 core cpu a 48 core gpu which
can be upgraded to 64 core a 32 core
neural engine 800 gigabytes a second
memory bandwidth and up to 120 gigs of
ram and a media engine that is double
that of the m1 max you do have the
ability to upgrade both versions to an
eight terabyte solid state drive and if
you happen to have four pro display xtrs
laying around you can connect them plus
a 4k tv to your mac studio the pro
display xdr is such a beautiful display
that if you do have the money to spend
on it definitely recommend it but let's
not forget we now have a less expensive
version with more features in the pro
display xdr which we'll get to that
studio display don't worry we're getting
to your moment one of the things that
i've loved so much about the new m1 chip
is the fact that this has allowed the
cooling of all of these devices to run
so much more efficiently that you really
hardly ever hear fans at all not only
does that improve the thermals but that
also assists with battery life like i
can go a whole day maybe two days of
just doing everyday normal tasks even
editing full-on youtube videos i don't
even have to think about the battery at
all so testing out this mac studio
i just want to tell you i am i'm upset
because in my mind i thought that this
wasn't something that i was going to get
i didn't need this i would get it purely
for the sake of testing and i would go
back to using my m1 max macbook and
that's where i was completely wrong
because the amount of performance that
this has while i've been editing all
this ak footage like now that i know how
powerful this is how this has given me
the ability to really upgrade my footage
to 8k seamlessly like i'm editing 8k
footage and it feels like it's 720p shot
on a freaking potato like it doesn't
even make sense i don't understand like
it is not computing in my mind how
powerful this is and before getting the
m1 max macbook i was using an entirely
specked out mac pro with
1.5 terabytes of ram that is so
unnecessary for what i'm doing on a
day-to-day basis i realize that but just
knowing that i have tested out the best
of the best computers and now this is
sitting on my desk at a starting price
of 39.99 obviously a mac studio does
have drawbacks because you do need a
monitor you do need a keyboard so this
is definitely something that is
predominantly a stay-at-home device but
i do travel a lot back and forth
visiting my family and you know what i
can do i can put that in my carry-on i
can take that home with me if i have a
display back at my parents house this is
mobile i mean i might not be able to
edit on the flight with this but i can
take this with me this also has support
for wi-fi six and bluetooth five that
was something that i was going to
mention earlier but then i got onto a
rant and forgot to say it so we're just
inserting it here and the mac studio has
a unique thermal architecture it pulls
air in through the airflow channels on
the bottom using double-sided blowers
and then pushes it back out through
these holes in the back something that i
read online that was actually kind of
surprising is that the m1 ultra version
of the mac studio weighs two pounds more
than the m1 max because it uses a
heavier copper cooling system where the
regular m1 max version utilizes an
aluminum heatsink now that does kind of
make sense since you are like legit
doubling the power of this machine by
upgrading to the ultra and this is
probably why we won't see an m1 ultra in
a macbook anytime soon or will we hard
to say i think this might be where the
new m2 chip will finally come into play
while we're here talking about airflow
and ports this has four thunderbolt
ports 10 gigabit ethernet two usb a hdmi
a 3.5 millimeter headphone jack that
will also support high impedance
headphones now on the front you have an
sd card slot and depending on which
model you choose the m1 max will have
two usb c ports and the m1 ultra will
have two thunderbolt 4 ports so we've
been talking a lot about the mac studio
we need a display to go with it and now
connected to the mac studio is this
beautiful studio display this is a 27
inch 5k retina screen with a built-in
camera speakers and microphone now the
time of recording this i've actually
edited the last three videos including
the one that you're watching right now
on the mac studio using only the studio
display speakers as my main audio output
and i haven't even thought twice about
needing headphones or any additional
speakers like i'm super impressed i've
also done a bunch of conference calls
and with supported conferencing
platforms like webex zoom and facetime
you're able to take full advantage of
center stage this camera is the same one
that is in the ipad pros and the new
ipad air this display actually has an
a13 bionic chip which also allows for
spatial audio the center stage feature
and hey siri now on the back it has
three usb c ports and one thunderbolt
that will also charge compatible
macbooks and or even fast charge a 14
inch macbook there's three stand
configurations the one that i have is
tilt adjustable at 15.99 the other is
tilt and height adjustable for 19.99 and
then there's an option for a vesa mount
adapter you can also choose a nano
texture for your display which is an
additional 300 to help reduce glare and
i cannot stress enough how much i love
the nano texture display it is so much
easier on the eyes and i've been using
it on my pro display xtr's for the past
couple of years and it has improved my
quality of work life significantly
speaking of pro display xdr comparing
these two displays is actually really
difficult because of the huge price
difference the pro display xdrs are
obviously better since they are a 32
inch 6k display up to 1600 nits of
brightness whereas the studio is 27 inch
6k 600 it's a brightness but the highest
end xdr is 7 000
i know so when you can almost get three
of these studio displays for the price
of one xtr um so to tie our entire
machine together we also have one of the
new keyboards this keyboard actually has
the touch id right here integrated into
the keyboard and this was first
introduced in the m1i max so i'm super
excited to see it now available for
order in full size with the number pad
overall i have been having such an
incredible experience on this mac studio
and this is the m1 ultra with 128 gigs
of ram with 2 terabyte solid state drive
now i normally almost always edit off of
external owc drives and this is actually
a 16 terabyte ssd raid so this is the
moment that i've been waiting for i get
to show you guys what i've been working
on so this is the ipad video some of you
may have seen it some of you may have
not but if you haven't already i'll put
a link in the description so you can
watch the full thing all shot ak on the
sony a1s i love looking at other
people's final cut timelines so here's
mine this is also running a beta version
of final cut which is kind of exciting
because you might notice these little
lines right here that is showing
duplicate footage in final cut which is
something that will be coming out very
soon i'm just going to drop in this
multi-cam timeline and what i love about
this is when you have one of these
timelines you can actually see all of
your angles over here so we only have
two angles and this is also kind of
processor intensive being able to play
back two streams of 8k in multicam and
see them all at the same time and why i
love multicam is i can just go one two
one two one two one two one two one look
at this i mean we're multi-cam switching
between these two 8k clips
love it do you remember how many was it
18 or 16
streams of prores 18 18. the
confirmation has been it has been
confirmed 18 streams of 8k prores
[Music]
so i have the entire project done it
definitely took longer than i thought it
should but this is all 8k footage and i
have it all in this timeline right here
so you can see everything is nicely
lined up and
i guess now we test it out so this is
all prores footage let's uh let's full
screen this and see what let's see what
happens
[Music]
this is also running off of that
external raid drive as well just for the
record
[Music]
i can't believe this like is this
necessary do we need this
maybe not me personally but i do feel
like if you are doing
really high-end processor intensive
projects with video with 3d if you're
working with ak if you're doing ar vr
like this machine
is you're too good for me and also like
this display the fact that i don't need
any other speakers i don't need to plug
anything else into it i have a built-in
webcam it's essentially everything that
anyone would need to basically start an
entire production like this is it right
here
so as predominantly a final cut editor
that has pretty much what i have been
testing out on here non-stop now my
friend armando has been helping me shoot
some videos recently and he's actually a
premiere editor so i had him bring a
premiere project today so that we can
get a chance to test that out so armando
let's see what you've got for us hey
guys my name is armando and i have a
youtube channel called mondo bites and
sometimes i come here and help justine
shoot some videos and she actually asked
me to come in and help her film some of
the new mac studio and also studio
display videos for her and at the same
time do a little test because i am an
adobe premiere pro user so typically
when i whenever i get a brand new
computer i test out premiere pro running
several projects that i've done in the
past and i have a couple of benchmarks
and this is one of my popular ones that
i've actually done on multiple computers
for example this project here on a mac
pro will render it in 10 minutes and six
seconds now this mac pro is upgraded and
it will run about 20
so what i want to do is compare this to
the mac pro and also my current pc i'm a
pc user and see how well it does now i
know this project will run really well
because i do have a macbook pro m1 max
when i run it on my macbook pro and one
max it runs perfectly fine and i
probably would expect it to do the same
here very smooth playback now this
particular project here is running sony
a7s iii canon r5 and canon c500 mark ii
xavc so these are very popular codecs
amongst creators and you know everything
playback very smooth we are using full
playback so
none of this like you know half playback
quarter everything full playback very
smooth high quality and i can tell you
this display is very beautiful really
digging it but the question is okay we
got the smooth playback no complaints
there and i will say adobe and apple
have been doing really good optimizing
this software to run really good on
these m1 chipsets so now what we're
going to do is see how fast this renders
it so i do have like i mentioned i have
a macbook pro m1 max and this particular
project finished in six minutes and 39
seconds so i'm very curious to see if
this will cut it in half because
essentially this is like having two
processors kind of join together so what
i'm gonna do here is i'm gonna bring my
stopwatch and then i'm going to render
this like i normally would for a youtube
video which i just go to export here and
i just use the default youtube preset
which is just 2160p so i'm going to go
ahead and hit export and start and then
here we go off to the races it's begun
now we're going to see how fast this
render time is so i'm going to have this
little stopwatch here i'm going to leave
it here and right now i can tell you
based on our current time and also the
time that's estimated should essentially
do it in under four minutes which is
crazy to think because apple stated that
this isn't their pro machine wow this is
this is insane
oh my gosh
it's at minute 30. look this is great
you're gonna make me spend some money
here my macbook pro did it which is
already very fast now keep in mind
that's a laptop this is more of a
desktop but i mean you're basically
doubling the chipset so it's like you're
getting the m1 ultra which is 2 m on
max's so in theory
it should basically do it in half the
time so far we are currently at 2
minutes and 10 seconds and we are
already at 65 so
this could
even beat my current
pc
which i love this is crazy i don't know
why i'm nervous because it's already
beat the time i think it will be yeah it
i think it'll definitely it'll
definitely be under four minutes which
is very impressive also you have uh well
i have photoshop logic and final cut
open and wait music i've got notes open
let's just show people this while it's
rendering because there's still time
there do you have a final cut project
that you're working on opened up i'm
gonna minimize this there's photoshop so
there's stuff happening in the
background we are at three minutes 30
about under 30 seconds left so this
could finish it in about three minutes
and 30 seconds again background projects
still rendering and i'm sipping my teeth
yeah we're going to go ahead and stop
this very soon here
oh my gosh it's even going faster yeah
yeah there it goes five four three
two
one okay and as soon as that thing
clears which technically means it's done
boom
three minutes
31 seconds and you even swapped over to
like final cut and brought that up too
so
that's pretty impressive like the fact
that that stuff is still open by the way
this is an 11 minute 39 second project
for those of you that think that adobe
premiere isn't optimized for apple
computers you are completely wrong 11
minute 39 second project renders in
three minutes 31 seconds and we're
talking 4k
this is incredible i just love that you
have this is like your benchmark project
so this isn't something that you've just
run once or twice like you've done this
so many times so you have a ton of stats
to back this up this isn't even the pro
what what is pro this is this is
probably pro's gonna be one minute
i can't even i'm shook i'm shook
thank you so much if you're an adobe
premiere pro user i will say you will
have a blast editing because it is just
buttery smooth and render times are
incredible good job apple you did an
amazing job
well thank you guys so much for watching
i had so much fun getting a chance to
check out the new mac studio and the
studio display i will be posting some
follow-up videos the one that i really
want to do is making an ultimate desk
setup and as you can see i've already
started that process so if you guys have
anything else that you would like for me
to test out please leave it in the
comments below this mac studio so far
has completely exceeded all of my
expectations and i cannot wait to get
editing on this video but you're already
watching it so i've already edited it
and it's done so with that i'll see you
guys in the next video make sure you
guys subscribe and be sure to hit the
bell so you'll be alerted when i post
new videos and make sure you check out
my tick tock ijustine instagram ijustine
twitter i just seen oh
my goodness that's a lot i'll see you
somewhere else bye
if you're watching this
don't forget the pace the pigs that's
true they said they saw that yesterday
[Music]